PRESIDENT BIDEN HITTING THE NEXT
TARGET IN AN ENDLESS INFLATION
BLAME UP LOOSE A AFTER PUTTING
THE FINGER AT PRUDEN,
REPUBLICANS, AND BIG MEAT.
BIDEN IS ALSO GOING AFTER BIG
OIL BY SENDING A STRONGLY WORDED
LETTER TO THE HEADS OF SEVEN OIL
COMPANIES, OH, BOY.
THREATENING TO USE EMERGENCY
POWERS IF THEY DON'T BOOST
SUPPLY AFTER BASHING THEM FOR
TURNING A PROFIT.
IT COMES AS GAS PRICES ARE HAVE
OFFICIALLY TOP $5 PER GALLON
WITH NO RELIEF IN SIGHT.
AND IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD THE
SKY-HIGH GAS PRICES THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS JUST BUY AN
EXPENSIVE ELECTRIC CAR.
HE FILLED UP YOUR EV BY CHARGING
AND HE FILLED UP YOUR GAS TANK
WITH GASOLINE AND YOU HAVE THE
SAME SIZE TANK YOU WOULD SAVE
$60 PER FILL UP BY GOING
ELECTRIC RATHER THAN USING
GASOLINE.
IT'S VERY COMPELLING BUT TO YOUR
POINT WE WANT TO BRING DOWN THE
PRICE AT THE POINT OF PURCHASE.
>> SHE KNOWS MONEY, SHE HAS
STOCK IN ELECTRIC VEHICLES I
BELIEVE.
BIDEN'S MARKS ARE SO LOW IN
INFLATION THAT EVEN CNN IS
TURNING ON HIM.
>> HOW DO YOU GAUGE BIDEN'S
PERFORMANCE READ?
>> AWFUL PIT ALL COMPARED TO
CARTER, LOOK AT THE DISAPPROVAL
RATE THE JOE BIDEN HAS AN
INFLATIONARY NOW.
IT'S OVER 70%.
CARTER WAS NOT EVEN THERE AT
THIS POINT IN MID-1900 -- WHEN
YOU'RE DOING WORSE THAN
JIMMY CARTER IS DOING IN THE
MINDS OF AMERICANS IN INFLATION
YOU KNOW THEY ARE HOLDING YOU
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CONDITIONS
CURRENTLY ON THE GROUNDS THAT
ARE HOARDING AMERICANS THEIR
POCKETBOOK.
>> HERE'S A COUPLE OF PIECES OF
POSITIVE NEWS WE ARE
OVERLOOKING.
AREN'T YOU HAPPY FOR
JIMMY CARTER THAT HE IS STILL
ALIVE TO SEE THAT HE'S NO LONGER
THE WORST PRESIDENT IN MODERN
TIMES?
IT'S A BIG DEAL FOR HIM AND HIS
LEGACY.
HE GETS TO BE HERE AND SEE THEM
NOT THE BAD GUY.
>> THE CARTER RENAISSANCE COME I
NEVER THOUGHT I'D EVER SEE IT IN
MY ENTIRE LIFE.
GREG, TAKE A TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE, SHALL WE?
LET'S GO BACK TO 2020.
WHEN A BARREL OF OIL WAS LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN A SLICE OF PIZZA.
DO YOU REMEMBER IT WENT NEGATIVE
FOR A WHILE FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS?
I THINK IT WAS LIKE LESS THAN $2
PER GALLON AND EXXONMOBIL HAD
ITS WORST YEAR EVER.
THEY LOST $22 BILLION.
THINGS TURNED AROUND AND DEMAND
WIND UP IN THE PRICE OF OIL WENT
BACK UP AND NOW THEY ARE MAKING
PROFIT.
JOE GETS FREAKED OUT BECAUSE
EVERY TIME THE GASOLINE PRICES
GO UP HIS APPROVAL RATING GOES
DOWN AND HE STARTED SCREAMING
AND THREATENING THESE OIL
EXECUTIVES.
EVAN TELLS THEM TO INCREASE
SUPPLY.
OKAY, HOW ABOUT THIS,
"NEW YORK TIMES," BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CANCELS DRILLING
SALES IN ALASKA AND
GULF OF MEXICO, THAT WAS IN MAY.
HOW'S THAT COULD HELP SUPPLY?
THESE SOILS EXECS HAVE TO BE
THINKING CAN YOU DO SOMETHING ON
PERMITS?
CAN YOU GET THE SEC HOW FAR
BACK?
CAN YOU MAKE THESE CRAZY RADICAL
LEFT-WING LAWYER STOPPED SUING
US EVERY TIME WE TRY TO START A
PROJECT, OR MAY BE BUILDING A
REFINERY.
WE HAVEN'T BUILT A MAJOR ONE
SINCE THE 1970s.
SO HE'S PANICKING, I DO SO THIS
COMING BECAUSE YOU RAN ON
GETTING RID OF FOSSIL FUELS.
THAT WAS A DIRECT QUOTE.
WE'LL PHASE THEM OUT.
THEN HE GETS IN THE OVAL AND HE
DOES EVERYTHING TO DO THAT
THROUGH LAWSUITS AND
REGULATIONS.
NOW THEY THINK HE IS BASICALLY
LIKE THE UNDERTAKER FOR THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT YOU OUT OF
BUSINESS IF YOU'RE HEADED ONE OF
THESE COMPANIES MONEY STARTS
FREAKING OUT BECAUSE HE IS CAN I
LOSE THE MIDTERMS AND POSSIBLY
THE NEXT ELECTION AND I ALWAYS
LIKE BUILT DRILL BABY DRILL.
JOE BIDEN HAS TURNED IN TO SAIL
UP SARAH PALIN HE'S GETTING THAT
DESPERATE.
AND NOW IS THREATENING TO
CONFISCATE THEIR PROFITS LIKE
SOME THIRD WORLD DICTATOR.
THIS IS NOT HOW THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
ACTING.
THIS IS NOT A COHERENT ENERGY
POLICY.
>> HE SEEMS TO BE REAPING WHAT
HE SEWED.
IS THAT THE PHRASE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DANA, I DO
THINK THE GOOD NEWS -- BECAUSE I
READ YOUR BOOK.
LIKE WHAT HAPPENED AFTER CARTER.
WE HAD EIGHT YEARS, THE REAGAN
REVOLUTION.
IF THIS IS CARTER 2.0, AREN'T WE
DO FOR SOMETHING REALLY BIG?
>> PERHAPS.
I MEAN THIS IS REALLY BAD AND
ALSO IT'S THE REFINING CAPACITY,
RIGHT?
IT'S NOT JUST GETTING THE OIL
OUT OF THE CROWD TO COME OF A
LOT OF REASON WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH REFINING CAPACITY.
A LOT OF THOSE WERE SHUT DOWN
DURING COVID.
AND THEY ARE UNDER THE THREAT OF
REGULATION CONSTANTLY SO WHY
WOULD YOU INVEST IN MORE
REFINING CAPACITY?
LET'S SAY THEY ARE LIKE LET'S
DRILL A FEW MORE HOLES COME YOU
CANNOT REFINE IT.
THERE IS A PROBLEM THERE.
THE OTHER THING I JUST CANNOT
STAND IS THE P.R. STUNT OF
SENDING A LETTER.
IT'S THE MOST WEAK THING THAT
YOU CAN DO WITH THE MEDIA RAN
WITH IT, THERE WERE HEADLINES
EVERYWHERE THE BIDEN IS CAN THE
SEND A LETTER TODAY.
THEY COULD CARE US, THEN HE
ASKED THE SECRETARY OF ENERGY
WAS STUCK IN THE END EV
INDUSTRY, HE HAS ASKED HER TO
CONVENE AN EMERGENCY MEETING ON
THE ISSUE.
NOW?
THEY ARE ALWAYS SO LATE.
>> I WONDER IF BIDEN WROTE THE
LETTER, PUT IT IN THE ENVELOPE
STOPPED, THEN CLIPPED IT ON THE
MAILBOX FRIDAY MAILMAN TO PICK
IT UP TO THAT'S WHAT MY MOTHER
USED TO DO.
GERALDO, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
ALL OF THE FINGER-POINTING?
THEY'RE SAYING THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO TRANSITION AMERICA'S EVIL
FOSSIL FUELS AND THE BLAME PUT
IN FOR IT.
CAN'T BE A GOOD THING IF YOU'RE
BLAMING EVERYBODY.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU, I'M
DELIGHTED THAT THE EV REVOLUTION
IS GETTING A PUSH BY THE
SHORTAGE AND THE FOSSIL FUEL
SECTOR.
SO I THINK WE WILL ALL
TRANSITION EVENTUALLY.
I DEPLORE THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS CAN GO TO
SAUDI ARABIA AND HORROR HIMSELF
TO THE SAUDIS TO ATTEMPT THEM TO
GET THEM TO INCREASE PRODUCTION.
I THINK IT'S REALLY UNSEEMLY.
A LETTER?
WHAT IS A LETTER.
WHERE IS THE ENERGY TO DO
SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE TO YOUR
POINT, RATHER THAN THE SILLY
WRITING OF A LETTER?
ONE PLACE I SUSPECT THAT WE
DIFFER IS YOUR GIVING BIG OIL A
GREEN LIGHT, OR A FREE PASS,
THERE IS NO DOUBT, BUT THAT THE
AVERAGE NET PROFIT MARGIN FOR
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER OF 2021 WAS
31.3%, THAT'S THE AVERAGE NET
PROFIT, 31.3%.
EXXON MADE 5.5 BILLION, CHEVRON
6.3 -- BIG OIL IS REAPING THE
WINDFALL WHEN THE REST OF US
HAVE TO PAY.
>> AREN'T YOU INVESTED IN BIG
OIL?
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE I AM.
I HAVEN'T CHECKED.
I DO NOT CONCEDE THAT POINT.
I'M NOT SPEAKING PERSONALLY.
I DRIVE A CAR THAT GETS 12 MILES
TO THE GALLON.
>> WHAT KIND OF CAR MIGHT THAT
BE?
IF YOU MENTIONED IT --
>> IT DOESN'T RHYME WITH
BENTLEY?
>> LAST WORD TO YOU.
CARE TO RESPOND?
>> FIRST OF ALL WHEN YOU SAY HE
IS WHORING HIMSELF TO THE SAUDIS
IT IS REALLY PROSTITUTING
HIMSELF.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT ONLY
UNFEELING, NOT ONLY DEMANDING
THAT WE SUFFER MORE, BUT THEY
ARE LYING TO US.
THEY LIED TO US EVERY DAY.
AND THEY DON'T FEEL THE PAIN
THAT SENIOR CITIZENS ARE FEELING
AND SO MANY AMERICANS ARE
FEELING.
EVERYONE OF US US HERE AT THIS
TABLE IS GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON IN MIDDLE AMERICA.
PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO DRIVE
TO WORK OR DRIVE TO THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS LYING.
HE GETS UP AND HE SAYS THERE'S
NO QUESTION PUTIN ISN'T
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INTENSE
FINANCIAL PAIN.
THAT'S A LIE, MR. PRESIDENT, AND
YOU KNOW IT.
WE KNOW WE HAVE 51% OF OUR
PETROLEUM, OUR GAS AND OIL FROM
CANADA.
8% FROM MEXICO.
AND IT WAS 8% FROM RUSSIA BEFORE
WE STARTED CUTTING BACK BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
SO TO BLAME EVERYTHING ON
RUSSIA -- SO WE GOT ALL OF OUR
CAST -- AND THEY ARE CORRUPT
TOO.
SHE VIOLATED THE STOCK
DISCLOSURE LAW NINE TIMES.
AND SHE HAD EXERCISE
$1.1 MILLION IN STOCK OPTIONS
AND ELECTRIC CARS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COUNTING ON US.
THEY DON'T FEEL OUR PAIN.
THEY ARE GIVING US A RUN AROUND
WITH A LETTER TO THE OIL
INDUSTRY, GIVE ME A BREAK.
AND THERE IS NO QUESTION -- LAST
MONTH BIDEN CANCELED ONE OF THE
MOST HIGH PROFILE OIL AND GAS
RESALE PENDING BEFORE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT US.
ALL THEY CARE ABOUT IS STUFFING
THEIR OWN POCKETS AND THE REST
OF US, BE WITH YOU.
>> I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
MONEY.
I THINK IT'S THE FACT THAT HE'S
NOT STEERING THE SHIP.
THESE DECISIONS ARE LIKE FROM
YOUNG WOKE STAFFERS WHO HATE
FOSSIL FUELS.
IT'S REALLY -- THEY DON'T CARE
THAT WE ARE BEING PUNISHED.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT GREED,
IT'S P.R. CONTROL.
>> YOU CAN'T BUY GREEN ELECTRIC
CARS.
>> I THINK IT IS CONTEMPT.
IT'S CONTEMPT FOR OUR SOCIETY IN
GENERAL.
IT DISGUSTS ME.
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
I WENT MADE AT THE OUTBACK,
JUDGE.
>> WHAT DID YOU HAVE?
>> SOME BAKED POTATO AND A STEAK
AND CREAMED SPINACH.
ONCE ELECTION COMING U